[Music]
Cersei Lannister the met queen whose end
many fans expected to see with Danny's
arrival of Westeros is still not only
alive and well but is also still on the
arm to round the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms however with the immigrants
coming to its end and we told the
enemy's Cersei's Maitre the year still
being around and waiting for the first
opportunity to kill her services rain is
inevitably coming to an early end so who
will put an end to the met Queen to
answer that we need to go back to the
opening scene of season 5 I called open
to premiere feature the flash back to
search his childhood and it contained a
prophecy of who she would marry how many
children she would have and how they
would die
Meggie said you will never read Prince
she will let the king you'll be queen
for a time then comes another younger
more beautiful to cast it down and take
all the whole dear may ghosts reveal to
Cersei that the king will had 20
children and she'll have three gold will
be their crowns gold their shrouds
almost all of the prophets already has
proven to be quite accurate
Cersei did not fight the prince she
married the king they both had children
but not together
King Robert father 20 bastards and Queen
Cersei at 3:00 with Jaime
when this aired two out of three search
the children were still alive by the end
of season six they all had their golden
crowns and shouts although everything
Maggy the Frog told to search in the
show already came true there's this one
part of the prophecy the show left out
but decided to eventually foreshadowed
in a season 7 premiere at the prophecy
of the one car a Song of Ice and Fire a
series of epic fantasy novels on which
the game of Thrones series is based
maggy's prophecy beside including
everything the show featured also
includes the line and when your tears
around you the one car shall represent
about your pale white throat and choke
the life from you the identity of
Circe's prophesied valonqar has been
heavily debated among the fans and
numerous suggestions have been made as
far the word valen carrying high
Valyrian means little brother
Cersei took this to mean Tyrion which is
part of why she hates him so much in the
book sir says become convinced that her
youngest brother is for valonqar she has
blamed him for the death of her mother
make his prophecy made three years after
Tyrians birth has served to make search
the despised and mistress Tyrion even
more
Tyrion being the valonqar would be a bit
too obvious Houdin Jaime Lannister
cercis twin brother is most often
identified as sir since Valen Carbide
phantom the most popular theory is that
Circe is missing the answer right in
front of Jamie all those searches Twain
is also her little brother as he was
born
etc another piece of information that
can be considered as supporting evidence
that this theory would be death both
Jamie and Cersei have often stated their
believes that their deaths are linked
they both claimed that because they came
into the world together they believed it
together as well
examples include James statement that he
cannot die while Cersei lives
they will die together as we were born
together Jaime finished Circe says if he
were dead I would know it we came into
this world together uncle he would not
go without me now watch closely this
frame from the season 7 premiere that
might have her shadow Jaime being the
villain card that will put an end to
Cersei above Cersei scared the words the
neck just about Jaime the fingers will
Jamie wrap his fingers sir answers his
neck you decide if Jamie's in fact
sources valonqar this prophecy will
likely come true in the final episode of
Game of Thrones as I don't see Cersei
dying anytime sooner how will it go down
it will all definitely build up to that
moment Cersei will grow more and more
mad and Jim will seek for his final
great deed for which he will be
remembered for basically Circe's long
anticipated downfall and death will be
caused by her becoming the met queen
Winterfell will fall early on in the
season and all the living will have to
retreat south his laning is the largest
city with its population of 1 million
innocent people and therefore they
cannot allow the night king to take it
because it would mean an end for the
living meaning that a final stand
against the night king will be at King's
Landing this is not coming as a huge
surprise since not only have leaked
photos confirmed a huge battle singing
planning but the capital has been
established as the main and most
important location investors it would
not make any sense to have the final
battle in Riverrun or diary it has to
take place at King's Landing and it will
so somewhere in the mid season John
Tenney an entire living side will decide
to go to the capital to face the great
and final battle
help Cersei defended since it's the
largest city of its population of 1
million people even though John and
interlink side is coming to Cersei say
it Cersei who's at this point gun fully
manned will be preparing a trap for them
Sir season game plan is to have all her
enemies both living and dead fighting
within a city of King's Landing
whereupon she would use wildfire and
burn them all search this plane in this
theory is basically to wait in the red
cape for the army of the day to preach
the city walls sent for the great battle
to take place inside a capital Cersei
would then burned all her enemies the
living in there using wildfire however
sir stevealot managed to pull up this
plan since the valonqar will stop her
the valonqar being the one who already
it's such a plan from happening during
Robert's rebellion Jamie Lannister will
stop Cersei from burning down the entire
capital to the ground
Jaime already did the huge sacrifice in
order to save hundreds of thousands of
innocent lives by killing the Mad King
and has ever since been called the
Kingslayer or should I say mocked
however Cersei now intends to do the
same Jaime will do noble sacrifice once
again but this time he will not trade it
with his honor this time it requires his
life
Jaime will kill the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms once again but this time people
will not mock his name this time
everyone will know that Jaime Lannister
is the savior of the city and the only
reason they're alive in this theory
Jaime obviously turns out to be dwellin
car and he will leave this world with
her as the mountain will likely kill
Jaime Jaime will be remembered as a hero
in this great deed will fulfill his
empty pages in the famous book of
brothers this would in my opinion be the
best possible way to execute the
valonqar prophecy but there are neither
popular theories as well there's a
theory suggesting that the valonqar
could be sirs his own child
the one she is pregnant with as it's in
fact the younger sibling to search his
previous three this searches for child
with her brother Jaime a lot of Game of
Thrones fans believe that Cersei is
pregnant civil lead in the Circe's death
who will die just like her mother in the
shell birth and when your tears said Jon
dude the one car shell represents about
your pale white throat and choke the
life from you the valonqar prophecy says
the main suspects up until now have been
services two younger brothers Tyrion and
Jaime but it seems that Circe's unborn
child may end up being the prophesied
valonqar as I already said Cersei
sunburned son would be a little brighter
too sir since then Jaime's three dead
children fulfilling the prophecy of the
valonqar
this would certainly be a strong tie to
the wasters his own mother died while
giving birth to Tyrion Cersei as always
held him responsible for their mother's
death so if this theory would come true
beside fulfilling the prophecy of the
valonqar it would also be some kind of
justice for Tyrion however out of all
the theories I brought in this video
this one has the least chance of coming
true why
services child could possibly fulfill
the prophecy of the banker and her death
in childbirth would certainly be poetic
but not only would it go against maggy's
prophecy but we also know for a fact
that the miscarriage was already
supposed to take place in the season 7
finale as Cersei was supposed to survive
it here as you can see we have the
season 7 finale leaked overview that
turned out to be almost a no percent
accurate and it included the Cersei
miscarriage scene it says in the middle
of the night sir she wakes up in her
bedroom something is wrong she
Abbadon grab the lantern to find that
her nightgown and bed are soaked in
blood she screams the reason why the
showrunner decided not to air this
crucial scene in season seven finale is
most likely because they decided to put
it in season 8 premiere so Circe's
unborn child being the valonqar most
likely will not come true there's one
more popular tyrion it offers the
valonqar that's not coming from house
lannister
maybe the frog prophesied to Cersei to
the valonqar younger sibling will kill
her but she did not say your valonqar
your younger sibling will kill you
meaning that the valonqar could possibly
be anyone in the story who has older
sibling the valonqar in high Valyrian
means little brighter meaning that some
male character will put an end to Cersei
or does it as we learn in season 7
Valyrian language is not really into
gender specificities this is why the
princess promised could be Danny the
prophecy of the prince that was promised
is gender neutral meaning that as Miss
Ann decided the proper translation of
the prophecy would be the prince or
princess that was promised will bring
the dawn
perhaps this word valonqar could also be
gender-neutral this revelation has led
to theory upon theory where people say
it could be anyone from our you start to
Danny who are also someone's little
siblings it could be urine it could be
same site could be Danny it could be
many characters but the one could make
the most sense outside Elena's her
family would be Arya Stark not only
certain areas infamous list of people
she is going to kill but Ari was already
on her way to King's Landing to kill her
in the beginning of season seven she was
a nice girl on our own heading to King's
Landing
I'm going to kill the Queen if not for
hot pie who told Aria about her family
being back at Winterfell and Jon Snow
being the king in the north or it would
already kill Cersei or at least attempt
to so perhaps in the final season she'll
finish what she started in the previous
one
some argue that are evil kill Jaime take
his face send this way come close to
Cersei and killer others argue that the
arm Bank upon realizing that they missed
it in the wrong ruler will hire the
faceless man to put an end to searches
madness jockey who then finally
reappeared Winterfell giving Arya this
task
although Arya did stay to jog in that
she is not no one but a stark of
Winterfell who does not plan to obey any
order nor to kill anyone for the
many-faced God she probably would not
refuse the task upon hearing the name of
a person whose death is required Cersei
Lannister if this theory comes true not
only would I remove one more name from
her list but the game Bowl would also go
down a long anticipated duel between the
mountain and the hound often referred to
by fans as cleganebowl has seemingly
been set for the final season center-cut
game would definitely help Arya kill
Cersei and as the hell party needs by
all means since with mounting on her way
Ari will not be able to kill Cersei or
even if she does she will not survive
much longer as the mountain would
probably kill her but if our goals with
centrical gain the two could sneak into
the red keep
arya would kill Cersei and center would
kill the mountain The Hound would
fulfill his promise that he gave to his
brother in the season 7 finale it's not
how it ends for your brother you know
who's coming for you you've always known
there have guys the most popular tier is
regarding who will be the one to kill
the met Queen and bring her rain to an
early end but at the same time a
long-awaited end I'm curious who you
think is the prophesied villain car so
make sure to let me know in the comment
section down below and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]